新別ポッドがはい
どっから来たの鈴岡から来ました種族かをわざわざ来たの
はい嘘でしょ
本当に
本当にハイずっと hi o
いろんな住んでスポットを回っててもう何だ
おすすめの場所とかありますあしらないもんねあーですよね暑夏学者の和田だ
そうですねもう彼女とのからずっとのう
道
別居しさん
駅さ設置しましたを大一番で起用それが一番ですねはいはーい
h が一番ですね愛知大好きです
トンネルだトンネルですよ小判がこれっ
プレ頭もちゃんねる
これが最後飛んでるぞ
小田原ピクニ the 書税
いろんな人のアレが出るんですよあればてるんですねそう
[音楽]
ブーブーありましたかわしま県の心霊スポットリーグでございますよと鹿児島県なん
ですけどどうなんでしょ
そんなね氏ね
は有名という話は聞かないんですけども以上ツイッターで聞いたところやっぱり
そこそこ心霊スポットこういうのがあるよっていうのが教えていただきました
教えて下さった皆様ありがとうございました twitter できてなんですけども
城山トンネルって言う場所がめちゃくちゃ怖いっていう話をききました
画像を見る混沌なく魚エッチ大好きへその情報
いたんで実際に僕も調べてみたんですけども城山公園飛んでるという場所がやっぱり
心霊スポットとしてちょっと名が挙がっておりましたトンネルなんですけどどんなまさ
かといいますと
主に大人の例が目撃されるという噂がありますでも城山では昔から森の中で首吊り自殺
の噂が多くれ死体がめっちゃ発見されているらしいです
ここらへん
stat なんです
だかさっきのうん弟子とも言ってたぞ飛んでるの中で音がみるみるかといってたんで
ここらへんの人からもそういう噂があるのかもしれません
トンネルすぐ水が安いですねもただそれは自体自殺で有名なスポットでさらに
よるこのトンネルを通ると入り口に0が目撃されるらしいです
それだけも元気に駅
づらいスキー
今ここにいるんですけどもうすぐ入ったらあるらしいですそこで20分ぐらいです
よしいきましょうかはい行きましょう
[音楽]
あって決闘遠いんだけど頑張るか考え
やって r ん
この纏ってます
まこ右で
船はまっすぐす
[音楽]
今季はボツ出せ
ん
[音楽]
こんばんわっはっはー
この
まぁでもなんかさっこの新神戸なきゃいけなかっん
私に入ってますこんなん
これかこれのことですかね
これかなええっ
は
[音楽]
なんかいてい
ねバイバイバイっ
鳥肌やばい
なんか探されてたよね痛い悩まずでいき超えた所
紀子様さんめっちゃ決めましたん
[音楽]
如何せん
月でこれなら違いの振り抜い
2しての保育園かという
ていません
んううううううございません
年履きも言ってですよ3つ下の声聞こえるけども
[音楽]
いるんじゃないかというじゃあこれでサーっていなかった時を
や毛布いってもししますよいっ
[音楽]
なんかなそう思うん
me
[音楽]
おばあちゃんの声ってが女の人の声まず聞こえてるの
メッツに聞こえましたね
んだなぁ
になっている
これだから絶対コレだ
あっているや負けなかった
鳥肌やばいんだけどじゃあ久々にアウェー感ですかおお
なんかシンガー語っている
ここでタクシー乗って帰ろはい
あっ追加がヤバイ気がすんだよねやっぱり暗いね
大丈夫
wl なんでマジでやばいまじいけばいいんだ
まで the 言われますよねん
vip ちょっと配れじゃないたぜんじゃないかこれ
クラブ等でおっ
私ん
うってねあったら分かります
a 無理無理無理本当に怖いんだけど
やばいですよこれ
まあ俺が多いたんだけどですよねっます買うかー
残りまずでわかってるんだけど8月9月デー
東区筒井
一間スムース
普通にやってくれる
よしもう帰ろ
待って待って待って松山待ってるんだ
またねまじません
えっ
そうだ
me
dea
あっはぁ